hello believe nation welcome to another
edition of the Evan Carmichael show I'm
your host Evan Carmichael I believe in
entrepreneurs and I'm excited to be here
with you today to help you grow your
business answer your questions take that
dream of yours and turn it into
something that's actually getting some
momentum that you're bringing in
customers that you're having a positive
impact on the world that's what this
show is all about now today I'm doing a
special mailbag edition so a lot of you
been writing into me and leaving
messages on my YouTube and Facebook and
Twitter and I thought I'd read some of
the questions that came in and answer
them for you in addition to taking your
calls because I love talking to you guys
too that's what makes the show so today
what I'm only talking about is how to
get started how to get started with your
business how to stay motivated how to
deal with creativity overload and
pitching advertisers so let's jump in
the first question was about how to get
started it came from William boa tang he
writes in to say I'm in college studying
fashion design and my dream is to become
an entrepreneur and own my own clothing
line but I don't seem to know how to
start or where to begin thank you this
is a great question and one that
everybody goes through is your starting
the business right you're you may not
have any entrepreneurs in your family
you may not have any entrepreneur role
models kind of growing up so how do you
get started how do you take that idea
that dream of yours into a tangible
business idea now my advice on that is
is uh maybe a little controversial maybe
a little against the grain I honestly
think that if you had zero experience in
business zero experience as an
entrepreneur the best thing you can do
is getting out of his his fashion
college go work for somebody yeah that's
right the guy who preaches entrepreneurs
telling you to go get a job and the
reason is you're gonna make a ton of
mistakes right this is a reason why
eighty percent of new businesses fail
this is a reason you're going to make a
lot of mistakes and too many
entrepreneurs jump in and they they put
all their their their money their
investments they make a shout any
retirement savings they take out a loan
they dive into their business they make
tons of
stakes and they end up feeling and nip
having to go back and get a job and do
the thing that they hate and so I would
say go find a job but not not just any
job not a job just to make you money go
find a job where you can learn something
so what I would do is try to find a
small company so if we're looking at
fashion go find a small fashion company
find the company where there's 10
employees or less where the founder is
doing something that you want to do you
know you can see yourself being this
person in the next couple years go work
for them go learn from them get paid to
make mistakes right get paid to make
industry contacts and connections get
paid to understand how the business
works and what I try to do as much as
possible as get as close to the
entrepreneur founder as you can so don't
just go and do whatever you were hired
to do right don't just go and do the one
thing that they said hey you know
William this is what we hired you to do
go do this look for ways to expand your
reach look for ways to learn more look
for ways to get as involved an in depth
as possible and you know any
entrepreneur you look at an entrepreneur
with the business of 10 employees or
less they're they're stretched right
there stretched to the max they're doing
so many projects and for an employee to
step up and say hey I'd like to get
involved in this project or hey I've got
some ideas to help you grow your
business hey I'd like to get involved in
this that's awesome right and and you do
it for paid do it for free whatever you
want to get in and get that experience
that extra experience on top of what
you're hired to do so that's my first
bit of advice is go work for someone who
is doing what you want to do and learn
from them because you will be able to
understand how the business works much
more quickly by working with someone
who's currently doing it then trying to
figure it all out yourself and that's
what most entrepreneurs do is they try
to figure it all out themselves and you
end up going out of business because you
don't have all the answers so start off
by working for somebody else that's okay
next number two is model success go find
someone who's done exactly what you want
to do and again not not some of the work
for but people who you look up to you
know look at people in the fashion
industry look at someone like a Calvin
Klein
Ralph Lauren look at how they got
started use their stories of success of
coming from nothing of having zero
connections and zero startup capital and
how did they overcome those odds you
know the fastest way to achieve any goal
is to model someone who's already gone
out and done it so in the first instance
we're doing it by going and getting the
job and modeling the entrepreneur face
to face the second why's your model and
someone has achieved a lot more success
someone who's accomplished much bigger
things and looking at their store 21
inspire you to let you know that yeah
you can do this you look at Calvin Klein
in Armani and all of these famous
fashion designers they started from
nothing right and looking at those
stories can help you stay motivated stay
inspired want to keep going on your
journey but to would also give you
specific ideas on what you could do to
get your business going specific
strategies how do they get their first
customer how did they come up with their
designs how did they market their
business how did they hire a team right
all of these lessons you don't have to
figure it all out yourself it's already
been done over and over and over and
over and over again so stop trying to
come up with every idea yourself and go
out and model those successful
strategies ok so number one go work for
someone else who's already doing what
you want to do number two model success
from famous entrepreneurs who are in
your industry and number three is start
on the side I'm a big fan of starting
I'm just not a big cleanup going all in
burning the bridges cashing in your
retirement savings selling every asset
you own to raise the capital to start
start small start on the side start by
moonlighting start by you have that job
and you're making your income but then
you're also starting you're not waiting
five years before you get something
going so start right now start with your
designs start trying to sell them start
trying to market them start trying to do
collaborations and work with people in
the industry right do that on the side
weekends evenings so you're getting
started you're getting some traction you
get any momentum because it's going to
take a long time typically for a
start-up to start getting some traction
so might as well start now and by the
time you know you're making a little bit
of money with your business the ideal
time to to kind of quit your job and go
into your business
full time is when you're making some
money from your part time business and
you feel like you've capped out like
you've learned everything you need to
learn at your job right if you stop
learning at your job and you're there
just for the paycheck that's mean it's
time to move on and ideally you're
making a little bit of money already
from your own business that you can
leave that jump in your company and go
full time ok so number one go work for
someone who's already doing it number
two models successful famous
entrepreneurs and number three start on
the side start part-time start right now
I want to share a quick story of how
this kind of saved my business and I
told this may be a couple times but my
first company was a software business
and I was struggling I was fresh out of
university I didn't know what to do I
was falling into the trap that most
entrepreneurs fall into him trying to do
everything myself and and I felt like I
was a smart guy you know I'd succeed in
everything i had done previously and I
felt like anything I applied myself to
if I worked hard at it then i would
start getting results with her school or
sports or music whatever if I practice
if I gave my all to it I would get
better and i would start seeing results
that wasn't happening in my business i
was applying myself i was working hard
you know i was eat sleeping breathing
bleeding this business and I wasn't
getting any results I wasn't getting any
momentum i was making three hundred
dollars a month i was i was not able to
survive and i told my partner one day
that I quit because it was it was too
hard it was too much I felt 0 self worth
and the turning point came for me when I
realized that I'm not the first guy to
try to do this before you know was I was
19 years old I was selling software I
was in a specific field that was really
a niche that there weren't a lot of
players in but I figured you know I'm
not the first guy to try to sell
software before who's the biggest
software company in the world and how
can I model their success and at the
time it was microsoft and so I looked at
Microsoft and look at Bill Gates our
founder and looked at how he got started
and the bigger the company is the easier
it is to find restoring how they got
started and I looked at how they did it
and they did it through partnerships
they found people
who were already selling to their target
audience and and they found ways to
partner up with them to expand the
Microsoft name and their big deal came
with IBM where every IBM shipped had
Microsoft software on it and that was
the deal that put microsoft on the map
the microsoft was already a seven
million dollar company when they made
that deal that's that's the small
company but that's nothing that's that's
like I would still rather be seven
million dollars is where I was and so I
copied that strategy and Microsoft got
27 million through partnerships and i
figured i could do partnerships as well
and i started researching who was
selling to my audience i was selling a
scientist so who's who else so was
selling to scientists and i found the
distributor my first deal was was in
europe and i sold him an upfront license
fee of 13 and a half thousand dollars to
sell my software and that that was that
was the light bulb moment for me because
finally I had a way to make money
finally you know that's not a lot of
money there can half thousand dollars
but but for me for me or in three
hundred dollars a month that was huge
and so these strategies worked stop
trying to do everything yourself number
one again William go out work for
someone who's doing is that you can
model from them learn from them number
two model 6x find a famous entreprenuer
wang calvin klein Giorgio Armani whoever
it is learn from them research their
beginnings not how they make an extra
million now but they're very start learn
from that and then start on the side
start your business right now part time
don't wait get some traction get some
momentum and continue to build up next
from the mailbag is Michelle Batson who
wrote in the same one of my biggest
problems is creativity overload how can
I find a way to turn this into a
business that help others who struggle
with this as well it's a great question
i think a lot of entrepreneurs we are
creative right you've got to be creative
bunch to be an entrepreneur and i think
the biggest thing if you want to turn
this into a business is you have to
solve it yourself right whatever problem
you're facing right now the opportunity
is in solving it before you can turn it
into a business so i think of it a lot
like franchise businesses before you can
franchise your business you need a
successful location yourself and so
Michelle I'd say you either need to
focus you know focus on one thing that
you really
creative in and that you want to you
know drive forward it pursues your kind
of life's mission and passion focus on
that or find a way that by being
creative you can apply that to other
people's business go prove the model
right go go be that creative spark for
other businesses and other entrepreneurs
and that leads you to your founding
story so you know you have to be able to
have a story that people can connect
with and by saying you know I was a
really creative person and I was
overloaded and then here are all the
struggles I went through and then here's
how I solved it right to build the
business you have to solve the problem
so either focus on on one specific thing
that you're really creative add that you
want to build a business around or go
help other people be creative and add
value to their businesses and once
you've figured out that model we've
solved that problem then you can apply
to other people who have that same issue
of creativity overload alright Michelle
good luck thanks to a great question I
want to get to the call so the show is
all about I have Antonio on the line
Antonia where are you from and how can I
help hi I'm Antonio from lufkin texas
texas welcome to the show thank you I
have this brand that I came up with it's
called just be you and i created this
brand from a personal experience when i
was 12 and I just don't know how to go
about getting my brand out to get people
to understand where I'm coming from with
the despi you now the dis be you came
from like I said when I was 12 I was
molested twice by my ex-boyfriend and no
one knew for a long long long time and
finally I was like it's cool i was
fighting all the time i was going to
alternative i was going to jail I was
like to do the whole bunch of negative
stuff as a younger person because I had
so much pain built up to where I was
like you know we're fighting and kristin
is not really just was going to solve
the problem I need to open up and let
people know this is what happened to me
and do something positive with it but I
don't know how to jump off with it you
kind of get where I'm going with it I'm
gonna start it off what is the message
behind
just for you know what are you trying to
tell people don't be afraid of what
happened get on get out of you know
whatever secrets have in the past it
goes from your sexuality it goes from
that all the way up to youjizz coming
out being but Ray I mean it is whatever
you want to be is just all anything just
be yourself you'll have to pretend to be
somebody or not and pretend to be
somebody that you try to be it's just
all so this just mean be yourself cool I
mean it's a fantastic message easy to
understand what I would suggest to you
is now drill down into different
segments so if it's for example people
who've suffered through child abuse like
you went through um what what should
they do like how do I be myself now
lagoo what are the steps that I need to
take so you're giving your giving the
motivational inspirational part of your
message but then also the practical
how-to steps on how to overcome it and
have a deal with it and maybe not solve
it but but you know lessen the pain and
make it easier for others who are going
through the same thing so if you have
your you know Antonio or just be you
methodology on how to attack each of
these issues then that that helps solve
the puzzle so it's more than just the
aspirational inspirational message at
the top but then also here like the five
seven ten steps that you need to do in
order to just be you and live a happier
life well instead you know it's just
complicated when you know you be how can
I put it you be a real sexuality is not
what really people would really like you
know you know it's kind of hard to get a
brand out when people's looking at you
because you just think so that that's
kind of like kind of hard when you're
trying to come up with this industry
space basically you know everybody's
very judgmental and I can't seem to get
around there like everywhere I go I
gotta bend houston i've been in dallas
you don't try to start a club promoting
with the shirts and stuff you know i
just been doing a lot of things it's
just that I can't get that um you know I
need to get to where I need to be and it
frustrates me it makes me mad I found
myself back to the same person that I
was before I started just for you
and I just need other ways to get around
and like that is just amazed I'm going
on this ongoing cycle this keep
continually playing in my head is over
and over again right okay so I empathize
with diamond and I mean an
entrepreneurship is hard I would I saw
two things for you one I would get over
the you're holding yourself back with
your belief that because you're gay
you're you're not going to be received
by people there's lots of people who are
gay who have great messages who who are
loved in America and and who have built
amazing brands and so we all have these
stories I used to tell myself when I was
19 and started my business I'm too young
nobody's gonna listen to me and it
wasn't till I broke through that
personal limiting belief that I achieved
more success so you know the short
answer on that one is for you just be
you be gay be proud be happy about it
right that's not that's not holding you
back it's part of who you are and that
empowers you to be more successful so
let go of that limiting belief and I
know it's hard but looking at gay
entrepreneurs who could be role models
for you Calvin Klein Ellen DeGeneres
whoever it is and knowing that you know
these people are achieving success in
part because they're gay not not in
spite of them being gay so that that's a
key kind of mental break through you
have to make on your own the second bit
is i would start making alliances this
is more kind of practical make alliances
of people who are targeting your same
audience so if there are there are
organizations there are businesses who
who are trying to help people who have
moved gone through child abuse right
those are the people you want to be
partnering up with and if it's t-shirts
or selling or ebook or whatever those
are the people who can directly
influence your market so I start making
a list of all the people who are we call
influencers to your market you know if
you were selling entrepreneurs you want
to talk to me because I'm an influencer
in the entrepreneur space so you want to
be talking to all the people who are
influencers in in the the child abuse
space as a good start and let them know
what you're all about what you do
the t-shirts your projects if you're
doing speaking whatever it is so they
can help spread your message for you
instead of you going out to one one one
one at a time you're talking to people
who can send your message to thousands
of people at a time wow I never really
looked at right babe all right lots to
work on Antonio thank you so much for
calling in and if you have more
questions I'm on every two weeks I'd
love to hear from you again okay not
thank you for having me all right take
care and for everybody listening listen
we all have these limiting personal
beliefs there's there's a story you're
telling yourself that's holding you back
whether it's your you're a woman you're
too old you're too young you're gay
you're you're an immigrant whatever it
is is all these stories it's only in
your head you got to break through that
and when you do you'll start to achieve
massive success with your business and
in your life this show is all about
turning your business dreams into a
success and we're doing mailbag edition
so I'm answering your questions next up
is soo mayor of Orden to say hi Evan
most people have dreams they watch lots
of motivational videos but when it comes
to doing stuff they just don't feel the
responsibility and keep on d'alene most
of the time they're not stuck in any
problem at all but they just don't want
to do it your thoughts on this would be
very helpful please staying motivated is
one of the hardest things that you have
to do as an entrepreneur because you
know you have these dreams you're all
excited you're you're working your butt
off you're putting everything in and
when you're not seeing results when
you're not seeing things come back
momentum from all the effort and love
that you're putting in it's frustrating
it always takes way longer than we think
it's always way harder than we think
even when people tell us that it still
doesn't prepare us for how hard it
really is and I often find that as
entrepreneurs we you know we may have
this a bold idea right we have that that
moment of boldness that we want to step
outside and do something big and and do
something that stretches our comfort
zone that we're afraid of and and then
you know you sleep on it and the next
thing you wake up in and you look where
did that idea go and you think that
that's that's stupid that's too silly
that's that I can't do that and you know
that the story you tell yourself kicks
in again
prevents you from doing something great
and so staying motivated is really hard
because you can be on top of the world
one day and the next day you're starting
over from scratch so here's some ideas
here's what I do it I think can really
help first of all you create an
environment because your environment
right now holds you where you are that
the people in your life the media you
consume that the music you listen to the
books you read your daily habits the
environment that you've created for
yourself hold you where you are and so
if you want to get to the next level
change your environment and and create a
routine that supports you create a
routine that reminds you that you're on
a path for greatness because if you
don't do that and you let your your
routine and your environment kind of
dictate what you do then you're never
going to achieve anything huge and so
you know for me I'll wake up and and
I'll put music on that that inspires me
already and gets me in the flow gets me
excited well then remember my big why
right what is my big why you have to
have a big why why are you doing this
why is it important to you why are you
why are you waking up every day why
don't you quit that job so you can do
this right what is your big why for me I
want to help a billion entrepreneurs
that that that motivates me that
inspires me and then have little wise
and your little wise are the things that
kind of every day keep you excited and
motivated for me it's honestly hearing
from you guys the comments on the radio
show the comments on my youtube channel
and Twitter and Facebook people writing
in saying averin your message really
helped me that stuff that keeps me
motivated right keeps me excited keeps
me knowing that what I'm doing is
important that's what you need you need
validation that the work that you're
doing is important to some people
because when you're not seeing money
when you're not seeing momentum you're
not seeing results you feel worthless
you feel you feel like you don't have
any value and so when you remind
yourself that yes I do have value yes I
am impact in some people's lives then
that makes it easier for you to get up
and go do more work and so I try to
create a schedule where I start with
that right that's my morning I look at
that every day so that I don't rely on
some random meeting happening at three
o'clock in afternoon and then a mile
excited I want to be excited from you
know the minute I wake up and so that's
what I do it create a schedule that that
supports me I think of my big wise and I
remember my little wise and so trying to
do that for yourself what kind of
schedule can you do what's in your
environment that is holding you back
that's not allowing you to be great
change it replace it with something that
does make you feel inspired and
motivated and thinking bigger remember
your big why why you're doing this
what's the big goal you try to
accomplish why is it important to you
write that down some more put in front
of your computer put it on your desk
somewhere so that you can see it and
then three is your little wise things
that customers have written in people
told you you know I used to have a
PowerPoint file that I kept of all the
notes of customers wrote in to me just
something you can look at every day and
remind yourself that yeah what I'm doing
is actually have an impact on people's
lives it's still hard but that's how I
stay motivated and and best of luck to
you because I know it's a challenge
going through that every day I have
Barbara on the line brahbrah where are
you from and how can I help i'm calling
from Rockingham North Carolina all right
welcome to the program what's going on
well I have 30 years restaurant of
retail management experience and I don't
want to work for anybody anymore I need
my own business but I'm so conflicted
with what type of business I want I
really want to to exploit the talents
that are in the Carolinas and make that
a business so I'm wondering if it should
be a talent agency I'm just I don't know
and how am I going to benefit I'm just
confused I don't know it's not enough
information for you to help me out
Barbara I am feeling your passion and
your pain here ok I'm feeling it
honestly the best thing for you to do is
to start exploring start trying stuff
without being a full-time business yet
without it being you know what you're
committing your money and resources to
start exploring so if you're thinking
about a talent agency try it right like
try helping one person out see if you
like it try working part-time moonlight
and a talent agency do you like it
doesn't make you [ __ ] a lot that's what
you need to find it's something that
makes you come alive and then you'll
find a way to turn that into a business
that all has to start around the passion
right so explore this different
opportunities
okay to jump from one thing to another
thing to another thing explore something
that you're excited about and see if you
fall in love with it to the point where
you want to turn it into a business so
the talent agency is one thing what are
some of your other ideas I was thinking
about a really really classy restaurant
because in my hometown we only hey
there's only like 95 people night and
ninety nine hundred people right so I
was thinking about and the only
full-scale restaurant we have it's fact
so I was thinking about a really really
nice restaurant on upscale restaurant
with a variety of food not just a steak
and chicken but a little bit of this a
little bit of that totally upscale I
just had an idea I had a written down
and I can't remember all of the details
but I want in an upscale restaurant I'll
bet that it was something totally
different than mine town has seen
everybody Barbara you have you have 30
years experience in the restaurant
business so that makes logical sense but
do you love the restaurant business love
it so why are you doing it why are you
finding the right partner and starting
that business why are you thinking about
a talent agency when you you have all
this experience in restaurants and i
love it so much but i have just as much
experience in image and telling business
i've been on the faces i was again i had
my own radio talk show I'm modeled in
Puerto Rico Germany Dallas Texas I'm
ready shows I've been on the stage I've
got that and just as much experience on
the stage probably more and i love that
even more that's what I love the most so
then go do that you love you just said
it right there you love that even more
that's what you love the most so that's
what you need to find out and explore
dive deep into that industry and see
where you fit it may be a talent agency
and maybe coaching people and maybe
setting up a media company you know you
have to you have to find your way
through you're not going to the idea you
come up with right now it's not going to
be the idea that you end up with and
that's okay but you have to start to
figure out what your plan is going to be
you got it you got to jump in what's
something you can do right now to start
testing it out Wow start just having a
little all shows right in my hometown
which is what I'm considering doing just
havin all souls right here in my
hometown what's holding you back from
doing that so why aren't you doing that
now what's holding you back oh well
because I was working full time on and
involved in a lot of other community
things for Martin Luther King's birthday
so now that that's over with I think I
can get so i'm going to write do it i am
that's exactly what I plan on doing I
love it so good start and then see if
you love it and see what you fall in
love with and see what direction that
takes you because that's that's got to
be your answer it has to be something
that you are passionate about something
that you love doing and and you'll
figure the rest out but you got to start
right like that's the key so many people
have these ideas they write them down
and they don't do anything with them and
and it's okay for the idea to change
like you may start putting on that show
and you guys are the show like that was
good but that's not really where my
burning passion is and you switch and
that's cool like it's okay to jump from
one thing to another thing it's way
better to not settle right don't settle
for something that's okay and keep the
lookout for something that's great okay
well I really appreciate your advice I
I'm glad that I get a chance to talk to
you today alright no problem Barbara
good luck and and for everybody
listening it's so critical to start a
business around your passion like here's
Barbara who who's been in the restaurant
business for 30 years and she likes it
but her real passion is something else
right so stop waiting jump in do
something try it out and and it's okay
not to have it all figured out you will
never have it all figured out from the
start it's not going to happen you're
going to make mistakes and that's okay
and you learn by getting in and doing
there just minimize the downside okay
don't go in and spend all this money
trying something try without spending
money see if you love it see what makes
you come alive see what you are deeply
passionate about and then find a way to
turn it into a business but it doesn't
happen unless you start so today has
been the mailbag addition I've been
answering your questions people have
been writing in to me leaving comments
on social media the next question is
from Peter
and he wrote in to say Evan I started an
online magazine my second edition of my
magazine is just one week old and I have
a thousand readers already my problem is
I don't know if I should use that as a
pitch to advertisers or if I should
continue with my branding process so
Peter first of all hey congratulations
man thousand readers after your second
edition has great progress I don't know
what you're doing to market yourself I
don't know who your target audience is
but that's great programs you should be
proud there's a lot of people who are
launching magazines and you know have a
really hard time getting readership so
so congrats to your success so far keep
it going now to answer your question i'm
a huge fan of embracing the genius of
the ant so a lot of times entrepreneurs
ask me questions like like this where
it's should i do this or should i do
that and and it's things that they want
they want to do both of them but they
can't work it out their head how to do
it that's the secret you got to combine
them find a way to do both don't live in
that black and white world work and I do
this or this the solution the best
answer is find a creative way to do both
Jim Collins has written a lot of great
books some of my favorites are built to
last and he was looking at companies
that went from from nothing to building
huge empires and then lasting not not
just building up and physically not
about lasting over generations and
generations and one of the common traits
between them was that they were
consistently embracing the genius of the
end so doing both try and finding things
that most people thought if I can only
do one or the other and doing both of
them together so that's the first so try
to do both one next thing they're going
to look at your circulation read Emma
graphics right you don't have a lot of
growth yet but but pitch it as this is
all that we're growing and is it
targeted right if it's a specific market
that somebody really wants to reach hey
that thousand readers could be really
special to them could be really valuable
to them I would also look at ninja
projects and things like approaching
known sponsors and look at them to do an
interview instead of asking for
advertising right away do an interview
with them do a story on them let them
know who you are what you're all about
I hope that they get some results right
by dou by being in your magazine they
got views they got leads and you know
they were able to see some results from
that then it's easy to follow up with
them and ask for an advertising value if
you go straight in and say hey advertise
online magazine you're up there with
everybody else is asking for ad dollars
so i look at ninja approaches to get in
to get them aware about your magazine
and what you're trying to do and once
they know you like you trust you it's
way easier to open up that conversation
to start selling advertising so that's
it one embrace the genius at the end due
both to look at your circulation your
demographics and see if you can really
hone in on a target audience that
sponsors want to work with and and three
use a ninja approach to try to get some
sponsors on board do a story on them let
them know you trust you like you and
then expand from there I have a time for
one quick caller show's almost out one
quick color I've got Maria on the line
Maria where are you from and how can I
help hi I'm from Long Island New York
and thank you for taking my call I know
you're very busy and you're helping so
many people it's wonderful thank you my
quick question is I wrote the TV pilot i
right I'm an actress I'm also a
private-duty nurse aesthetician I do
several different businesses and my
question is I have two stories and I'm
trying to debate one is very humorous
and it's really good for the soul and
the heart the other one it's not a dark
story but it shows the reality of what
money can do to some people not everyone
but some people in the medical field and
I'm not sure my question is do i do it
as two different projects you might have
answered the question I know what the
last person you are speaking to or can I
incorporate that maybe one episode into
my storyline I mean it's pretty major
horrific things that we're going on with
this one family and it's not that I want
to end on a negative note because I want
to empower people and let them know what
goes on behind the scenes as the private
duty nurse I see a lot of wonderful
people wonderful medical doctors but I
also see people that are exploiting the
elderly
so my question is should I have that
incorporate that in my storyline or do
it as two separate entities yeah that's
a great question and honestly I would
look at what do you what feels right you
know what what are you looking at TV
shows what do you think is missing from
TV shows because you can you can you can
shine line on a certain issue through
different ways you can shine light on on
elderly abuse through showing really
dark stories or you can also shine light
on things through comedy and so it's
seen you know what what approach do you
feel more passionate about I'm very
passionate about comedy and empowering
people I I would much rather focus on
the good in every scenario now sometimes
family members of mine think i'm in la
la land but there are so many good
people out there so my focus would be on
the good but still you know giving the
knowledge out because people need to be
aware and i think that i can do it in a
positive way of showing God's love
without being super religious or being
showing the dark side because it's not
all about that there are a lot of good
people and I've worked with them I've
had I've been blessed enough and
fortunate enough to work with them so i
guess i will put it back in your court i
love it i mean there's so much if you
look at the meeting you look at the news
it's always that you know if it bleeds
it leads right it's always a negative
it's always a bad stuff that's happening
and i think you can definitely shine a
light on something you can even shine a
light on something negative but do it in
a positive way and say this is a really
bad situation but here's how these
heroes are stepping up and solving it
and so it could be an inspirational tone
it could be you could do it through
comedy if you like as well I really
strongly urge you to figure out one what
is the message that you want to get out
there and to what is the the style the
approach that you want to attack it with
and figure out what what means the most
to you like what what feels right what's
missing on TV right now that nobody is
doing that this is what people are
really going to connect with it can work
either way but it's more down to your
personality absolutely correct and
I appreciate that and I think it is
about giving people hope I love a Maria
we've got it we've got to cut it off but
thank you so much for the call that's
the lock on the show another great
episode thank you guys everybody Christy
Josh my producers everybody listening
we'll be back in two weeks stay tuned
have a great couple weeks keep believing
and I'll see you soon hi ever kill
English here with mermaid junkutv are
you on Evans newsletter subscription if
not you should be I read every single
one and you should too channel
you